[Music]
what
hello dear friends once again thank you
for joining us here on this beautiful
program that I know is one of your
favorite which is I'd like to know we
thank you for your comments your uh
questions that you sent to us and it
really allows us to connect with you to
connect with the audience and allowing
us to respond and answer the questions
that you have in mind we want to remind
you you can send your questions to
tvam tv.org uh again that's TV at Sam
tv.org and that way you get the question
in we'll try to answer as soon as we can
very in mind that we have a lot of
questions ahead of yours so please be
patient and allow us to answer to them
in the order which we receive and
hopefully we can get it to you as soon
as possible well today we have I have
the privilege to be with Pastor Steven
bore Pastor what a blessing to have you
here once again thank you for being in
this program it's always a privilege to
be here with you on this one of our
favorite programs here at secret
unsealed yes and a favorite of many who
watch the program as well absolutely and
we really thank you because you are the
ones that make this program possible we
thank you for your prayers as well as
for your contributions to keep this
program on our programs uh of the
ministry uh live by sending your uh
contributions and your financial support
which is really appreciated well Pastor
as we are going to open these uh set of
questions can we please uh ask the Lord
to guide us into all Truth by praying
let's pray Father in heaven we thank you
so much that in a world that is so
confused where people don't know where
to turn we know exactly where to turn
amen it's to your word to the spirit of
Prophecy to find answers to the most
pressing questions of Life many times we
have questions that are
academic just uh Curiosities we want to
know uh certain things that don't have
to do with our salvation but some of the
questions are life and death questions
and so as we negotiate these questions
today we ask that your holy spirit will
be with us to guide our thoughts to
guide our words and to prepare us for
the events that soon will transpire in
this world Amen and we thank you for
hearing and answering our prayer we ask
it in Jesus name amen amen
amen thank you Pastor we're going to go
start uh the question question from a
friend of ours sent whose name is
yariel and he's from Puerto Rico what a
blessing to have someone Rico answer
send us a question the question is the
following I just arrived from church
from a SDA Church where I had a worship
leader say that Jesus chose to imprison
himself in a human body forever so he's
no longer omnipresent nor he'll ever
never be again I'd like to know if this
is biblical thus true and
so he heard in a presentation by a
leader from the church stating that
Jesus himself became imprisoned in a
human body forever and he has lost some
of his um God attributes I suppose which
is uh he could no longer be omnipresent
how true is this yeah he he also
provides a little context in the last
part of the uh question mhm uh context
she was trying to explain evidently it's
a woman who's presenting the topic uh
she was trying to explain how great is
God's son's love that he even renounced
to some of his Divine attributes forever
so that we could be
saved um you know there's uh two
different views with regards to the
omniscience and omnipresence of Christ
uh some people believe that he there
during his Incarnation he limited the
use of his omniscience others believe
that he lost his omniscience and his
omnipresence um I believe that Jesus
when he became incarnate chose to become
a man in every sense he became our
brother right um whether he limits the
use of his uh powers of his divine
nature or not uh you know that's a
debate that's ongoing mhm uh I find it
very difficult that Jesus uh the the
Divinity of Christ could actually limit
one attribute of God why not his
omnipotence why not his
omniscience why only his
omnipresence um I find it difficult that
God could limit one of his attributes uh
without uh limiting all of his other
attributes after all Jesus is the god
man he's 100% God and he's 100 % man and
so uh I believe that Jesus still has his
divine nature but he has chosen to live
as one of us he's chosen to live as a
man amen amen Pastor that is that is
probably the right answer and I think
that I mean it's nothing wrong to
emphasize what he had to give up to
become men you know I mean obviously who
in the right mind would give up being
you know God um you know uh and becoming
something that is limited that is a
create a created being just to save us
but because he loved us and that's the
emphasis that the Bible speaks of you
know that the love that we cannot
understand that goes beyond our
comprehension is what made the Father
the Son and the Holy Spirit choose this
path of Redemption where Jesus had to
become man and give up um who he was
fully to embrace Humanity to become one
with us be one just like us in order to
you know redeem us so it's something
that perhaps we cannot really answer
fully and this is how in a sense you
know for eternity we will be studying
the depth of the love of God how much he
had to you know how much it really cost
heaven to to to give that opport for
mankind to be redeemed so uh but I guess
we have to be careful not to like you
mentioned Li limit
God Jesus who he is as God at the same
time because it might be uh we might be
making a mistake in in declaring
something that the Bible has not
declared itself to be so you have to be
careful with that as well I think yeah
you know uh the classic passage that
talks about what Jesus
left uh and uh what he embraced when he
came here is in uh uh
Thessalonians where it says who was in
the form of God and the word form there
is morphe MHM it doesn't mean that he
just had the form of God the the word
morphe in Greek means
substance in other words being of the
substance of God being fully 100% God
yeah he made himself of no reputation
Philippians 2 6 through 7 yeah taking
the form of a servant uh and and being
in the form of a man and a servant he
humbled himself even more yeah taking
the the uh suffering death on the cross
and then it says therefore the father
has highly exalted him and given him the
name that is above every name uh so you
know this has been a passage that has
caused huge debates in the theological
world what did Jesus leave in heaven did
he leave his Divine attributes up there
to become a man or did he have his
Divine attributes here while he was a
man Ellen White makes it very clear that
while he was on Earth he was still 100%
God right and 100% man yes but he
limited the use of his Divine powers
only by permission of his father um he
could not for example use his divine
power his Divine omniscience to detect
Satan's deceptions right he had to
overcome like a man yeah he couldn't be
present everywhere at the same time
because he chose to limit the use of his
Divine attributes but he still was God
while he was on Earth and still had his
Divine attributes right you know an
example of this is um Ellen White states
that before Jesus came to this
world he saw the entire plan of his
Earthly Ministry he saw every detail of
his Earthly Ministry he knew everything
that was going to happen but she says
that while he was on Earth The Father
revealed to him day by day what he was
supposed to do that day mhm and so um
basically Jesus while he was on Earth
did not have a picture of the total plan
because it wouldn't have been a test
because he would have known the whole
thing from the start right and so uh
Jesus I believe limited the use of his
divine power but he still had those
powers and he could have used them his
Humanity could have attempted to use the
Divine Powers now God can't be tempted
his divinity would not have would not
have uh U committed sin sin but his
Humanity could choose to attempt to use
the Divinity to escape Temptation or to
take revenge on someone Etc so it was
the use that he limited not the
possession of uh the Divine attributes
and you know that is a very interesting
point Pastor because if we can think of
I mean we as humans cannot be
tempted to tap into a divine you know
aspect of us because we are we just have
one nature we have one just one
dimension if you will uh but Christ had
not only to be tempted in every Point as
man but he even went above us in many
ways because he had that possibility as
you mention as a human he could have
tapped into that aspect of his Divine
Divinity to perform miracles to save
himself or to supply for his needs and
he never did that uh he fought
everything every battle temptation as a
man does when when has the devil ever
tempted you to turn stones into
bread exactly you know it's not a
Temptation for us because we can't do it
exactly but but Jesus could right he
could appeal to his divine power to term
stones into into bread but he uh acted
only in harmony with his father's will
his father directed every single act of
his life amen and that's the reason why
he was Victorious and Ellen White says
that the same can be true of us amen
amen that's right that's exactly what
the Lord wants us to do I would
recommend uh before we go on to the next
question I would recommend that those
who are watching the program read the
first chapter of Desire of Ages the
title is God With Us uh there it says
that when Jesus assumed Humanity he took
Humanity to retain his human nature
forever forever he's going to be be our
brother he's going to be flesh of our
flesh and bone of our bones amen and uh
that's just an awesome thought to think
that you know if we had s if we had
never
sinned Jesus would be God right he would
not be one of ush but because of sin he
not only is one with the father amen
he's one with us as well what a glorious
thought it is a glorious thought and
this is where we will be forever in debt
to him because he became our brother
um and and he even will wear for you
know the signs of the of his death
forever amen you know what a blessing to
know that he loves us that much um let's
continue the next question the next
question uh comes to us from the UK and
it says the following um I have only
just found an SDA church I am currently
learning the Bible I am worried that I
do not have enough time to reach the
standard that God wants us to be before
the end of probation I believe it took
Ellen White a long time to stop eating
meat I'm anxious that I don't have time
to correct behaviors that have cured
Creed over my 43 years what does the
Bible say about those late to the church
but genuinely want to change first of
all I want to really encourage our
friend here to um to know that you know
what a blessing it is that she's or he
is is you know determined to uh
to change and that he you know wants to
change or wants to be one uh one of
those that really stand for the truth
and and Embraces everything and grows
everything so I think that the first
thing we got to encourage this person is
to to not get discouraged you know
because changes are are are not
happening as fast as you want them to be
uh but anyway Pastor what else can we
say about to this friend of ours here
well no there's a passage in the Bible
that I I think will help her MH uh it's
in Matthew chapter
20 Matthew chapter 20 it's the it's the
parable of uh the workers that would
call to the vineyard MH at different
hours of the day yeah you know you had
one group that was called at 6 o00 in
the morning yeah at 9:00 there were
still more laborers that were needed so
at 9:00 you know went to the place where
everybody was waiting for a job and
recruited some more at noon they needed
more workers yet and at 3:00 in the
afternoon they needed more and finally
at the 11th Hour at 5 at 5:00 in the
afternoon then the final workers were
called and the interesting thing is that
at the end of the day all of them were
paid the same mhm the 11th Hour workers
represent those who adopt and embrace
the Adventist message last or late if
you will yeah late in history absolutely
uh Ellen White makes that point very
clear right she speaks of the 11th Hour
workers that will be very active in
finishing the work and God will do with
with them in a short time what would
take normally years to do uh because of
the outpouring of the of the holy spirit
in the latter Reign amen that things
will mature and ripen very quickly and
so don't be
discouraged uh you know and say well you
know uh Ellen White took years years
which is true to overcome meat eating
but she finally gained the victory um
you know commit yourself to the Lord and
you can do it in a short period of time
you know I can talk about my wife my
wife is from Colombia she grew up eating
meat and uh you know she ate meat until
uh during the first 14 years of her
marriage but then she made a decision
she's went to a restaurant she says I'm
not going to eat meat anymore and since
that day she's never eaten meat she
can't stand it now can't stand the smell
can't stand the look right uh but you
know it was just a momentary decision
she said no more and she didn't eat it
anymore and that was a long time ago
many many years ago I'm not going to say
how
many no I know it is true Pastor you
know I I've seen and I heard of cases
where people who have struggled with
certain things for many years um and you
know they have tried all sorts of things
to quit you know programs and the kind
of thing and they haven't been able to
and sometimes it's the fact that we
haven't really taken that matter to
Christ and be really saying Lord put in
me that that new experience of changing
that behavior that habit that taste you
know and God can do that change if we
really submit and are willing to give
that up to the Lord often times we just
don't want to and a struggle becomes
when we uh you know we say we want by by
from our lips but in our actions in our
real deciders we're not willing to let
go uh so ultimately I think that changes
can happen very very fast uh and like
you mentioned you know that's a promise
to us and so I think this a friend of
ours here that has written this message
can get the encouragement that as she's
willing to grow in Grace Christ will
give her the Victory and what seems what
may seem that is going to impossible to
do he can help her to do it very quickly
you know I can I've seen cases not
people have told me I've seen cases yeah
where individuals quit smoking instantly
mhm and they don't feel any they don't
feel bad or anything you know uh craving
um the lord gave them because they cried
out to the Lord the lord gave them an
instantaneous Victory amen over smoking
right and the same with people who drink
right you know my my grandfather my my
father's father um passed away many many
years ago when I was a child and you
know he had a tremendous struggle with
alcohol I mean it lasted quite a long
period of time but the lord gave him a
victory but there's others where it's
instantaneous yeah and so you know you
don't have to think well you know it's
going to take years to overcome this the
Lord can perform Miracles and he can do
it today amen amen praise the lord we
know that he can change and he willing
to change you know every aspect of Our
Lives if we are willing to let him do
that to us um we have another question
this is uh from a friend who ask to be
anonymous and it says uh greetings my
friend dove into shallow water hid his
head and drowned he was pulled out of
the water and revived at the hospital it
was discovered that he had broken his
neck and was paralyzed quadriplegic and
would not recover from his
paralysis how can he be
baptized but baptism by immersion is is
expecting too much from him this is a
very uh very uh personal sad story uh
Pastor you know somebody that has had to
go through that experience must be very
crucial so what could we say to someone
like this I mean isn't provision in the
word of God for people that cannot
absolutely be
baptized you know I've done
baptisms where the Elders of the church
get into the baptistry mhm and and I
baptize people who have been in a
wheelchair mhm uh you have to actually
four of you have to put the person under
the water and take the person out again
so it is possible to do uh with a
quadriplegic it it's it's possible to
baptize such a person but we need to
also remember that God takes into
account uh circumstances that do not
allow for a baptism you know take for
example the thief on the cross right you
know mhm why didn't he get baptized well
because he was on the cross you know and
some people use that as as an excuse
they say uh you know the thief on the
cross was never baptized and what I tell
them is you're not a thief and you're
not on the
cross so so there are
circumstances where uh where a person
physically cannot get baptized and God
understands the motivation of the person
the person had every intention of
getting baptized so the a quadia can be
baptized it takes more than the pastor
in the baptistry it takes several to
take the person and uh you know dip them
under the water um so you know I I think
that's the way we need to look at this
absolutely maybe it maybe won't be be
able to do in the in a necessarily in
the church baptistry maybe it's too
small or what not but could be done
perhaps in a pool or some you know body
of water where he could be submerged uh
and like you said if the example of
someone that cannot be for whatever
circumstances you know that is really
Beyond humanly possible well Jesus
provided the you know through his
example for those that like the thief of
the Cross who could be baptized as well
you know the the the last baptism that I
did which is similar to that a lady who
was uh bound to
wheelchair quite quite an old lady uh
was in the San Jose Spanish church and
uh that was probably four or five years
ago
and uh the elders you know there were
three elders and myself and uh we uh
baptized her under the water amen uh so
it is possible to do it's not easy but
it is possible if the person insists
right right amen so hopefully this is
the case I mean the most important thing
is that he can look forward to the new
Heaven and new earth where he will have
a perfect body and that person you know
can be restored to fullness Health uh we
have time perhaps for one more
question again this is from someone who
wants to remain anonymous and it says in
Ephesians 13 and 14 and Ephesians
4:30 it speaks about the seal and
sealing by the holy spirit is this the
same seal ceiling found in Revelation 73
and 4 it almost sounds as if the sealing
is a process or a series of steps by the
holy spirit will you please elaborate on
this thank you God
bless okay the this there's two rains
that the Bible talks about the early
rain and the L rain right the early
Reign Begins the the personal walk of a
of an individual with Jesus the latter
rign matures the character of the person
uh and prepares them to go through the
time of trouble um the the the early
Reign the Seal of the early Reign MH is
the Holy Spirit
according to uh Ephesians 13 and4
Ephesians 4:30 it's the guarantee that
God is going to fulfill his promise
absolutely uh so that's what I call the
gospel seal whereas Revelation 73 and4
is talking about the eschatological seal
the end time seal that God gives when
the person has received the latter reign
of the Holy Spirit their character has
been totally matured and the Sabbath of
course is the sign that that person is
totally committed to the Lord so there's
no contradiction there's a gospel seal
and there's an eschatological seal the
gospel seal is the holy spirit beginning
the process of Christian growth right
the eschatological seal matures the
person and then the seal is the Capstone
of the process in the life of the person
amen I mean this is where why Ephesians
mentions that Earnest or guarantee you
know that the gospel does in your life
that ceiling that beginning process of
changing your life uh and the promise by
Holy Spirit to make you fit for heaven
through the changing through the en
nobling through the sanctification
process uh and as you mentioned Pastor
right at the very end during the end of
Christ's intercession for us he will
send or he is in the process of sealing
his servants where they will have
received the Seal of God
that you know change or that sealing of
of the truth settling the truth as spir
of mentions where we will not longer
move away from honoring God those that
are faithful those that have the seing
the seal where we no longer be possible
to them to deviate from the truth you
know where they will be sealed for to
pass through the time of intercession
that time of I'm sorry that time of
travel that time of tribulation without
an intercessor because they have that
receive that seal of God in their
foreheads so um one aspect is what God
does now that's the beginning of the of
the sealing of the Gospel Dimension the
other aspect is the result of that
experience when we are sealed for
eternity to have that character like
Christ and pass through tribulation
without intercession yeah the first the
first seal is the down payment yes the
earnest right the the earnest yeah the
down payment or the guarantee yeah the
final seal is the Capstone it brings the
process to an end and the purpose of the
seal in Revelation chapter 7 is twofold
number
one it has the the person has the name
yeah of God on their forehead right that
means that they totally belong to the
lord it's an identifying characteristics
and Ellen White says that the angels can
read the name in the character of the
person but it's invisible to
humanize and and then secondly it is a
sign of protection in other words
they're they're closely related because
in the case of uh us belonging to Jesus
during the time of trouble Jesus is
going to say their mind yeah you can't
touch them MH and so it's a seal of
identification of those who are true
followers of Jesus and the Seal of
protection to them because they are the
Lords and Christ when he finished the
ceiling of his elect when he has
finished his work he declares those
words where you know those that are holy
will be holy still those that are just
will be just still and also
unfortunately for the for the Lost
they're no longer able to be sealed
there's no longer a possibility for them
to turn their lives around or come back
to the Lord I mean he declares them let
he that is unjust be unjust still and he
that is filthy let be filthy still in
other words is no more opportunity for
no human being to change or to repent or
to come back to God there are also
sealed by the devil right because they
receive the mark of the beast yeah on
the forehead or on their right hand so
there's two groups of sealed people at
the end of time right one group is
sealed by the Lord and the other is
sealed by the devil amen let's hope that
we can be sealed by the Lord and not by
the enemy you know and and I think this
is why we are to receive that Earnest
now that down payment if you will so
that we can and and we need to choose to
sustain ourselves or stain ourselves and
you know align with God so that we can
continue that process of sanctification
till the Lord can truly see his
character in us and give us a seing
Contin continually receive the early
rain so that from a seed a plant grows
plant grows into a tree and then
ultimately bears fruit amen well time
has gone up uh in history may God God
bless you hope to see you next time see
you and may God bless
[Music]
you